in order to support the growth of an
organism cells need to grow and divide
after a point of time cells also need to
die so there are two categories of gene
one which promotes cell division
proliferation and growth known as
proto-oncogenes and other category is
tumor suppressor gene which prevent the
excessive growth of the cells or a
tissue so any uncontrolled mutation
uncontrolled proliferation would be a
cause of cancer now any gain of function
mutation in the proton Co gene or loss
of function mutation in tumor suppressor
gene might lead to uncontrolled
deviation which would ultimately lead to
cancer right now it is important to
understand any loss of function mutation
in proton in tumor suppressor genes
would create cancer so tumor suppressor
as the name suggests this suppress
formation of tumor now tumor suppressor
genes fall under two broad categories
one are called gatekeeper and another
category is known as caretaker the
gatekeepers are those tumor suppressor
genes or product of those tumor
suppressor genes which would directly
suppress the growth and caretakers
overall maintain the genetic stability
as a result the chance of mutation is
reduced if the caretakers are
functioning properly now cell cycle
regulatory genes and cell cycle
checkpoint control genes fall under
these gatekeeper category
apart from that genes which control
apoptosis is also in this category where
as caretakers involve mostly DNA repair
proteins and several proteins which are
which are important for maintaining DNA
integrity and all now we know that at g1
phase mitogenic signals come and the
mitogenic signals ultimately give rise
to cycling deep
so anything which would prevent cycling
be activation would be called as a tumor
suppressor gene
we know that PRB normally stop the
progression of the cell cycle from g1 to
s by sequestering e to F and now cycling
DN cdk4
prevent that and phosphorylate p RB to
free e to F so p RB is an important
tumor suppressor gene because when p RB
is non-functional
the growth and proliferation occurs but
in a normal state p RB make sure that
the cell cycle does not exit from g1 to
s so let's say there is a tamiya net
damage now there are two options one
option is to kill the cell second option
is to give the cell some time to halt
and correct its mistake so the option 1
is basically triggered by p21 which is
itself
transcribed by p53 now both p53 p21 they
suppress the activity directly or
indirectly of cyclin d and silica for
complex so without that the cell cycle
would halt at G 1 to s transition that
is why these p21 or p53 they are both
tumor suppressor not only that if for
extreme cases where the damage is
irreparable and irreversible that
situation there are specific the
specific proteins such as pax bad bead
all PCL family proteins which would
induce apoptosis
now these proteins would be also
considered as tumor suppressor because
they normally kill the cell and ensures
uncontrolled proliferation or growth
doesn't take place so there are two
family of proteins CIP family and I NK 4
family which inhibits cyclin D and
silica for complex
activity so all of these are tumor
suppressor genes now tumor suppressor
genes at extreme cases can lead to
apoptosis for example p53 which is a
tumor suppressor gene can coordinate
with other tumor suppressor genes such
as pax and allow Beck's transcription
when Beck's is transcribed and
translated backs create four small holes
on the mitochondrial membrane as a
result cytochrome C is coming out in
them as IRAs all that interacts with a
puff one to activate caspase-3 R by
bringing about apoptosis so the pax p53
all these which regulate growth and
apoptosis are tumor suppressor genes now
we come to DNA damage we definitely know
if the DNA damage is there and the
genome is replicated in that situation
and this damage is not repaired properly
then at a mRNA level or at a protein
level there could be mutant proteins
right that could have a mutant
functionality so overall damage in the
DNA could be detrimental force in so
that's why cell has surveillance
mechanism sale has repair mechanism that
can find out where is the damage and can
repair the damage so these DNA damage
repair and surveillance measures
machineries are part of tumor suppressor
genes and they fall under the caretaker
category they have house they have a
housekeeping function so they ensures
that overall genomic stability and
integrity is maintained one great
example is the mutations in the genes of
nucleotide excision repair caused the
cancer syndrome of pigmentosum which is
as cancer of the skin so tumor
suppressor genes are absolutely
important for normal growth so for
checking normal growth and ensuring
uncontrolled growth cannot happen I hope
you enjoyed this video if you like my
video give a thumbs up don't